[تصفيق]
15000 زائر بيدعموا 200 منتج مصري في مكان
واحد لهدف واحد
انا ليزا اكرم عندي 33 سنه اتخرجت من
اكاديميه بحريه
والنهارده انا كنت
ابتديت مشواري من زمان شويه
دلع حاجه لعلمتني تنظيم اساسا وهي دي
الحاجه اللي ادتني الثقه ان انا اقدر اخد
قرارات او ان انا اقدر ان انا اقدر انظم
حاجه وان انا ابقى مسؤوله عنها وكان هو
السبب الاساسي النهارده التطوع الخيري
تطوع الخيري هو اللي وصلني ان انا ابقى
واقفه النهارده وبتكلم بثقه عن ايفنت
بتحمل مسئوليه 200 عارض
و15,000 زائر في يوم واحد نقدر ناخد
قرارات سريعه ونقدر ان احنا ناخذ الرزق
تعالوا كده اخدكم معي قصه زمان
جدودنا ازاي كانوا اساسا بيشجعوا المنتج
المصري وكانوا اساسا هو المنتج المصري كان
الاساس بتاعهم كان جدودنا طول الوقت زمان
هم اللي بيشتروا قماش ويروحوا عند الترزي
يصنعوا يشتروا من وسط البلد يروحوا عمر
افندي كانت كلها زمان اساسا في الاساس
كانت منتجات مصريه اكل مصري كنا بنجيب
الملايات الفوط كان اساسا المنتج المصري
هو الاساس مع مرور الزمن والترانز
والسوشيال ميديا والمولز والاستيراد الناس
اتجهت ان هي تتعامل وان هي تبتدي تجرب
منتجات ااا
يعني عشان البرانس وحصل بينها وبين المنتج
المصري ااا يعني
مع الوقت لما جت لي فكره قلقي ماركت هو
بيجمع في اليوم الواحد 200 براند مصري
ايدي مصريه
بينتج
يعني
بيجمع
حاجه ناقصانه في المجتمع بتاعنا وهو
الماضي اي واحده محجبه هنا هتبقى عارفه ان
هي لما هتنزل مول مش هتلاقيه بسهوله منتج
مصري يقدر ان احنا نلاقيه بسهوله
يخدم الحجاب او يكمل الحته دي
فقلقي ماركت هو الوكل وان ستوب لاي واحده
محجبه او لاي واحده مصريه حابه ان هي تدعم
سيدات بينتجوا مشاريع ميه في الميه مصر
كانت بدايتنا كانت بدايه مش سهله خالص
ابتدينا بزيرويرز على الانستجرام ابتدينا
ما كانتش الناس فاهمه قوي ايه المنتج
المصري غير لسه يعني انا ابتديت من اربع
سنين حوالي من سنتين ابتدت الناس ان هي
تشجع وتنزل وتتفرج وتجرب وتنتقد او تحب او
تدي تعليقات عليه مع الوقت ومع
كذا ايفنت وكذا
[موسيقى]
تعرضنا لها الحمد لله النهارده وصلنا ان
احنا بيبقى في اليوم يبقى معنا 15,000
معنا 200 براند معنا 1800 براند على
الويتنج ليست مستنيين ان هم ياخدوا الفرصه
بتاعتهم
[موسيقى]
ازاي وصلنا اصلا بقى ان احنا يعني استادت
تعرفنا شويه وابتدت تدعمنا بطرق كتيره قوي
انفلونسرز وان احنا ابتدينا
اهم حاجه كانت بالنسبه لنا ان احنا نسمع
شكوه الزائر علشان احنا نحسنها ان هم
نديهم كورسز ندعم بها
البرامدا ان هو ياخد كورسز ويطور من نفسه
عشان يوصل ان هو يقدر ينفذ المنتج همم
المنتج البريميوم او الانترناشونال اللي
في المول
كانت كل ايفنت وكل يعني فتره بيقابلنا
تشالنجز كثيره قوي اللوكيشن
طب الناس هتعمل ايه مثلا في مشكله الدولار
هل الناس هتنزل تدعم المنتج لا مش هتنزل
للناس هتبقى خايفه اصلا ان هي تشتري طب
الناس عندهم ثقه فينا فكانت التشالنجز
كلها ان احنا نحاول ان احنا نوصل للناس
همم نوصل
للاند كاستمر اللي هو انت هتيجي هتشتري
منتج عمرك ما هتندم عليه بالعكس هو منتج
يعني
هيفيد بلدك وهيدعم اقتصادها
طيب سؤال حد هنا لابس مصري اللي لابس مصري
يرفع ايده
اوكي تمام
انا النهارده لابسه مصري في رومات 2 ما
فيش اي حاجه في لبسي مستورده انا فخوره ان
انا اقول ان انا بجد شايفه ان المنتج
المصري ايا كان نوعه ايه هو منتج احسن
بكثير من اي منتج مستورد في اي مول او اون
لاين لما بنسافر نجيبه همم على الاقل انا
كواحده محجبه يوم ما بلاقي ان انا عايزه
اشتري حاجه ما بحاولش ان انا اروح واطول
فيها والبس تحتيها حاجه خلاص انا بقيت
لاقيه لا يعني عندي زون ان انا في براند
بتدعمني كده كده في اي مناسبه
طيب ايه هم اصلا اللوك البراند ايه هو
المنتج المصري يعني
المنتج المصري هو منتج ميه في الميه متصنع
في بلدي بمنتجات مصريه او حتى لو
بماتيريال مستورده فهو متصنع بعيد مصريه
مصانع مصريه فهي سايكل كبيره قوي
بتبقى فاتحه بيوت ناس كثيره وبتدعم
الاقتصاد بتاعنا
عندنا يعني دفينز من اللوكنز عندنا جزم
وشنط فود هوم لبس اطفال ايا كان هو ايه
احنا نقدر نصنعه في البلد طول ما احنا
عندنا
ما تيجي تقدر ان هي تساعدنا ان احنا نطلع
بجوده عالميه وكمان بقى عندنا بتصدر بره
مصر منتجاتها لدول الخليج وامريكا وفي
كمان ناس تطلع حاجتها في اوروبا
اهم حاجه ان احنا لازم دايما نفتكر ان
احنا اننا يوم ما بروح اشتري منتج مصري
ويوم ان انا ما بروح ان انا ادعم ايا كان
براند سواء كانت اونلاين او في بازار انا
كده بقوي من الاقتصاد بتاع بلدي انا كده
بفضل سايبه الكبيره قوي شغاله بفتح فرص
لشباب كثيره تقدر تكمل شغل شباب او سيدات
مين دي
فانا وانسى ان انا ابتديت ان انا اصافي
الديزاينر ده او سبورت فكره براند فانا
بتقوي من بلدي بتقوي من اقتصاد بلد ممكن
يقوم بشباب يقدروا يفتحوا بيوت وما
يعتمدوش على الاستيراد او ان احنا نعتمد
دايما ان احنا منتظرين كل حاجه نجيبها من
بره بلدنا
في الاخر انا عايزه اشكركم جدا النهارده
وعايزه اشكر التيم اللي ساعدني جدا
النهارده ان انا ابقى موجوده واقفه هنا
وفخوره جدا ان انا لابسه في رومات توم
مصري فخوره بكل ديزاينر المصريه
اشتغلت على نفسها ان هي توصل ان احنا يبقى
كان عندنا الحمد لله لبس الماضي خلاص ما
بقاش موجود فخوره بكل ديزاينر مصري وصل ان
هو يعمل ديزاينز تعبر عن ثقافتنا
والمجتمع بتاعنا وهويتنا فخوره ان انا
كمان وصلت ان انا الحمد لله اللي ربنا
كرمني ان انا اقدر ابقى يعني سبب صغير في
ارزاق ناس كثيره
وخليكم واخيرا شكرا وخليكم دائما عندكم
ثقه في المحل شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]